PHILIP TAN: So
one thought that I
have for educators who are
running those classes is
be very clear to yourself and
then to the students about
whether you are running a
class about game design,
or game programming,
or project management.
When we started
this class, we were
trying to be as clear as
possible to the students.
This is a class
project management.
You will do all
those other things
in the process of this
class, and many of you
are here for that reason.
But that's the important thing
that we want you to understand.
And it is important because
it gives you clarity
as an educator on
how you're going
to be assessing your students,
how you're going to be teaching
your students, what you're going
to be valuing over the other.
The game can be poorly
designed and maybe have bugs,
but the team clearly
understands how
to communicate with each other.
Well, that is a
team that should be
awarded for their work, at least
in the version that we teach.
Other schools are
definitely free to have
a different perspective on this.
It could be about
the quality of code.
It could be about how
brave the students were
when it came to design.
And you can award
it accordingly,
but you've got to be very,
very clear both to yourself
and to the students.